The set up is simple. All you need is an Android
device, a USB cable, and your development machine. Let's take a look.
Before you get started you need to turn on the Developer Mode
in your Android device. This may be different on any given device
and you can check your device's manual on how to do this.
In many cases though, you need to go to your device's settings,
click on About Device and then click on Build Number seven times.
Seriously. Next you'll want to turn on USB debugging. Again, this varies slightly
on your given device, but this is usually located in the developer options.
We also need to make sure we have the right tools installed. On my
laptop, I have Chrome Canary and on
my mobile device, I have Chrome Beta installed.